let's go to Miranda from where is
Miranda from is it San San Diego so I
see SA
Miranda from uh sa Texas okay where is
SA Texas
San Antonio
got beautiful great to have you on
Miranda you're on the air but it seems
as though your connection leaves a
little bit to be desired let's see if we
can hear you if you try to say something
can you hear me better yes I can
okay awesome so I wanted to ask you
um what are your thoughts I read an
article recently um with the local news
about Ted Cruz and how he's basically a
shoe-in for his Senate see it's up for
re-election next year and I just wanted
to know if you how you felt about Ted
Cruz and
um basically they're saying there's
really no competitors to that seat and
it's kind of disappointing you know I
did love Bethel and I you know did a
bunch of rallies with him and went out
there met him talked to him so many
times and I really wish that he would
run again I don't know if he would win
um because he has lost you know multiple
times but I would love if he ran again I
haven't really heard of anybody else no
so I don't know if you've heard of
anybody or if you have any hopes well I
always have hopes it would always be a
delight to see Ted Cruz defeated you
you're correctly assessing that Beto was
one of the toughest Challengers that one
could have in a Texas Race and Cruz is
up for re-election next year I've not
heard that Beto is looking at running
there's I can't think of anyone else for
whom there's more enthusiasm and Beto
also was not successful so that is a
question when you say well even someone
as popular and well like this beta was
not able to win is there anyone who
could defeat Ted Cruz I don't know you
know it's a I'm I'm was kind of
withholding judgment and we've still got
some time and it would be a great thing
but obviously if I'm totally realistic
with you uh it's it's going to be a
tough one to to win for sure
right yeah and I agree and you know that
reading that article was
just so disappointing because I don't
understand how he's so you know well
liked in certain areas I mean it just
doesn't make sense I don't understand
how anybody could be for Ted Cruz I mean
I don't really know what he's done for
us but you know I get it everybody has
their people that they like so I'm just
hopeful that maybe Bethel will come
forward and run again or we can soon
hear of somebody you know great running
I'm with you I'm with it would be I mean
I obviously eventually Ted Cruz will no
longer be in the Senate either because
he will die or he will quit or he will
lose
um I would love to see it be because he
loses that would really be a great thing
um but let's see who presents themselves
let's see who shows up to face him in
2024.
thanks so much David I really appreciate
it all right Miranda from San Antonio
great to hear from you let's take the
quickest of quick breaks but if you're
on the phone hang on because I'm going
to get right back to calls in a moment